welcome to this video yeah this is a new
video with the tactics trainer from
chess calm the tactics trainer videos
were immensely popular so I decided to
make this a regular feature the Sunday
probably will feature the tactics
trainer video from now on in addition to
what's already on the channel so there
will be regular Sunday blitz stuff some
instructional content and also the
tactics trainer and that's pretty nice
promised I will do a varying level here
of tactics so I will do it I think 1500
last time and going up yeah and see what
what I can do this is the 2000 level and
note that the time is already quite a
bit quite higher because I well I had to
fix the whole of the battle recording to
be honest this is a little bit like
cheating because what I was setting up
everything I also had a peek at the
position and now can tell you the
solution to this pretty much instantly
yeah we see that in this position here
wide is also faced with a direct meeting
friend yeah this Queen age one is a maid
threat so we don't really have any any
time to waste we need to checkmate black
and we have lots of pieces in the attack
basically all of our pieces are
participating and the mating on sequence
is very forced white starts with Bishop
before check after which this only rook
p7 as a sensible move now we see blacks
King this matter really doesn't have any
square yeah it's a it's it's quite it's
quite funny we are very close if we look
at the knight to the smothered mate
thing 97 and in fact we can get a
smothered medium with a bunch of forcing
moves this is the first one after which
he only has
rook takes p8 and now we need to give
another rook on a 7 he can only take
with the bishop and now finally we get
in 97
checkmate quite quite cute yeah we had
had the night on b5 all the time but the
mate square was protected multiple times
it's relatively easy because it's always
just one response but like that's
possible okay so a nice one I don't
think we need the analysis spot for that
next one so we're going to play wide I
guess yeah we're going to play white
okay so what do we have him it's some
position by widest sacrifice the pawn
but white has a number of things going
for him
good active piece of strong bishop on d5
and very active very active pieces the
rook things like that so what what's
happening here
yeah we I guess need to do something on
the e-file yeah if we look at this those
pieces are not very well coordinated
flex pieces if you think about Bishop c6
takes vc6 rook e1 we attack the queen
and the bishop only 7 yeah
and here's Queen c5 check unfortunately
two to save the day so the question is
can we somehow improve on this this move
on if we give the check if he play rook
e1 first you know you probably will play
Queen g5 and then Bishop c6 you can give
the check go to h1 what we what we've
gained here we've gained a temple so
rook e1 I think will win the piece I'm
pretty sure about that
going to do that yeah the Queen has to
go somewhere on the fifth ring I guess
and now we take and remove the defender
of the e7 Bishop the check we just go to
the side so that we can just safely take
the bishop not quite sure why this is mm
not so not so difficult really okay next
one
aha we are playing we are playing black
okay so hmm what do we see in this
position yeah it's quite clear that we
have lots of pieces pointed towards the
Kings side the rook on g8 is looking at
the g2 pawn and met the King and we also
have this bishops pointing aggressively
to the to the Kings side yeah the first
thing that comes to my mind yes is the
move Knight to e5 yeah this is sort of
opening up the long diagonal threatening
Knight takes f3 with ya winning
everything and I'm not so sure what
White's replies now it takes a three is
a very strong threat and we also attack
on d3
yeah then the bishop on d3 so let's say
if after night and that's not even
possible
yeah 95 is simply winning I think we
will win at least piece note that if
white plays Knight to e1 ninety five
ninety one we are going to take on g2
and play Knight f3 winning the Queen so
I think Knight e5 should should win this
I don't think there is a defense now I
guess that should be such a solution
yeah here I can take on f3 and win win
this piece yeah Bishop takes Bishop
takes
wins apiece yeah it's um it's um pretty
pretty straightforward the long diagonal
is the key point we should for this
briefly look at the analysis but simply
because there's one line that I want to
show 95 if white is going to play 91
yeah trying to protect g2 covering d3 in
this case black has a very effective
move and capturing on g2 we can actually
yeah it's probably both winning but if
we do this it's it's it's much more
forcing smashing through with this nice
form here and we have won the Queen and
yeah we are we're still in this huge
diagonal the Juche diagonal is still in
our favor so pretty straightforward win
with 95 typically using the strong long
diagonal Bishop okay so the next one
okay so we're going to play Wyatt
okay Black has just canceled
yeah what are key features of this
position mm-hmm let's check we have one
point up hooray we win the endgame now I
guess there's some there's something
better
yeah what's very M thing is that this
Queen might might play a role this Queen
is unprotected and also quite I I think
I spot the solution also quite quite
problematic are those two pieces on D
787 those those are not protected it's
often a year useful thing to check in
your own camp and in your opponent's
camp
what are unprotected pieces not simply
for the fact that okay sometimes they're
unprotected and you can just take them
that's the very simple kind but very
often in a position that has many
unprotected pieces there's something
wrong there's something of there's not a
good coordination not not some sort of
harmonious teamplay going on and this is
one of those cases we have three pieces
unprotected Bab like the knight the
bishop and the Queen and we can use this
with the move Queen c6 and the big point
is if we go Queen c6 yeah think about it
the knight is attacked
what should like do can move the knight
or protect it
yeah and in both cases White has a
fantastic resource I put it on the board
because I'm pretty sure this is a
solution Knight f6 is the same thing and
now we see the big point the queen is
not protected on c2 and we have this
great move that will win win as a piece
because ii 7 now fort psmith check and
we take you have you even gained a gain
in exchange on top of that so this is
this is really really nice and it shows
very much
I put put up the analysis board again it
shows very much that those unprotected
pieces on d7 ECM and on c2 these pieces
are the key to the to the to the wynia
for white they are unprotected and
they're not playing together and with
exactly Queen c6 we can use that yeah
it's a very nice motif on also the Queen
on c6 using thus this kind of opposition
yes this is line up on the C files that
95s Possible's very cute
okay so the next one okay I'm playing
white and yeah it's it's pretty clear we
we need to we need to checkmate again
and here we have a typical case of the
Arabian mate the Arabian mate has one of
my favorite checkmates
probably the one reason why I spotted
the solution basically immediately yeah
here white wins by this as I mentioned
Arabian mate what's the Arabian made
yeah I'm going to put it on the board
you maybe have seen it before but to be
honest I also after 20 more years of
chess only recently learned that it's
called the Arabian mate so how is it
going white is taking on g7 check like
has to recapture there's really nothing
else otherwise we play Queen h6 and win
immediately so next we give the check on
f6 this is now possible as we after the
sacrifice have this square available
King h8 is the only move and now we see
that the knight on age 6 is ready for
capturing ok and here we have a case
where we don't even need the Arabian
mate to be honest
Queen takes g7 is the immediate mate
what I actually saw is I mean I'm not
sure what it is doing now if I had play
Queen 8 yourself this is what I saw but
this is of course the direct mode and
I'm going to do this just because I want
the the problem solved
problem solved text but we can go in the
analysis board on the analysis board and
check this check this again this check
black has no move if he goes to h8
community success is very simple so he
has to take with boobs to take with the
rook we give the check again only one
move we take yeah and here there's
really no alternative rook h7 there is
Queen f8 made or rook g8 made and this
is in fact the Arabian made the knight
and the rook on g8 o h7 to deliver meat
I actually saw him some
different after the bishop I said what I
saw I didn't see Queen g7
I only saw that because this is one of
those kind of favorite maids of mine so
I'm it's useful to do to have your your
face and chest you see them quicker than
the things that you don't really like
that much okay and next one oh that's a
pretty simply most simplified position
interesting so we have an endgame here
basically where black has looking pawn
against two bishops and yeah for points
against five points oh look at porn
against two bishops hmm interesting
what however is pretty clear that we
have again a situation where yeah
whether the pieces are unprotected both
bishops are not protected so together
with with the King on everyone there
might be possibilities to just win one
of the bishops so let's let's consider
let's consider what we need to do here
is to UM to look at basically yeah
forcing moves there are attacks by the
rook against the bishops against the
pawn on a3 and we also have this motif
of a check against the king so let's say
check we cannot do that c1 is protected
by the bishop but Luke c1 check King
moves up Roxy to and we win the bishop
so it's probably a combination of
various of those ideas and if we come to
the conclusion that we should check
those various possibilities I think one
move that what will stick out is rook c3
rook c3 is very useful because it does a
multitude of things that the text the
bishop protects the pawn and it keeps
the look on the importancy file where we
have rook c1 c2
so rooks III will probably win the thing
Bishop d2 replay look-see - walking this
is the fork yeah I don't know does a
rook fork we wouldn't want when we win
one of the bishops they're both
unprotected rooks it through roots III
Bishop f2 we can take a three yeah
attacking the bishop it only has to be
one and then rook a one another way to
win this piece on a2 so I can put it on
the board this is the solution bishop
deform yeah and here we have yet another
way to win the bishop the one that i
mentioned before with the two checks and
then we we just capture capture on a -
yeah he had no way out the bishops that
are both unprotected again unprotected
pieces are the key those those are
simply yeah they're not able to fight
this this active rook okay I guess we
don't need to know this analysis board
for that okay we play black here let's
see hmm it looks like there should be
something on f2 like Knight age three
years looks very close to win if not a
win night night night h3g takes Queen
after checking edge one Queen f2 is made
and if we give the check and the rook
takes ayah then we can check on e4
because it's a back rank mate queenie
for rookie for loop do you want made so
this blue win you know and now not all
f2 this is not leading to anything but
we can check here because it's a group
t1 made Nakia actually lets us play it
out so this was was relatively
relatively simple one of those cases
where we want to check to check the
checks first and it was clear that it
should be something with the rook on the
on the second rank
okay so let's see the next one
let's look this looks like a big attack
on the GFR hmm
yeah the question is is this one of
those cases where we can deliver mate
with both rooks on G and H file I guess
if you imagine the whole situation with
G and H from this is clutter of pieces H
5 g 5 and so on removed and rooks on G 3
and H 3 we will have a maid so I think
Bishop h6 is the solution because after
Luke takes I mean we are we were
threatening Bishop evade and things like
that now we can sacrifice the Queen the
King takes and now look G 5 for rook F 3
mate and black has no defense yeah this
is some pretty pretty straightforward
what we briefly should check is in the
analysis board that Queen takes h6 which
might come to mind is it's less good
because now there is no there is not
forced to take on h6 and
here black is just a queen up okay so we
want to take instead as we shown as we
had shown here and now we threatened
tons of discoveries with with the bishop
so like really yeah rook h6 leads to
mate but there is nothing better okay
the next one okay
it is our move and having really a piece
down hmm
it just looks weird that right is a
piece down in this position okay the
solution here is is very very or
features a very common motif in fact
it's a motif that I recently had in one
of my blitz games and it's the kind of
motif once you have seen it you you get
to see the solutions of those kind of
her problems relatively quickly white
here wins with rook takes d7
why quincy form is a move that
immediately comes to mind made on g7 the
night on f5 and the Queen on g4 is a
huge is huge to attack however after
Queen G form black might have some sort
of defense Queen f6 for example which
gives up the bishop on d7 but it makes
sure that black is not getting mated
however if we take on d7 in this
position and the Queen recaptures then
queen g4 wins immediately with retina on
g7 checkmate and we threaten Knight xh6
winning the Queen
so rook takes d7 looks very very strong
however if I think about this hmm t 7 I
mean black might play Queen to to f6
how are we winning them
I really wonder if there's a piece
missing here for white and like a bishop
on b3 or something
look t7 Queen f6 obviously white can
take on c7 something like that and have
a good position but it's close to
winning actually but I wonder if maybe
it's there something something that I'm
missing something better
look t7 looks looks like in the solution
they are probably probably it is the
solution yeah I was just yeah okay well
this is this is trivia no I win the
Queen but I was thinking Queen f6 that
likes like athlete this is not losing
the Queen the the kind of thing that
needs to be remembered here for this
motive is the Queen needs to be
unprotected here on on d7 and we've got
this immediate main threat and 9 th 6 &
9 h6 Queen Jews have made this kind of
combination what irritated me here is if
we pull up the analysis board I was
thinking that black might look like we
never 6 I know it does not really this
is not not great but I just thought that
okay well I can take c7 and probably
just win but I didn't see anything
better here like winning the queen or
Pisa or whatever so it's just rook c7
okay
it was a bit irritated by this
possibility this position looks also to
me like it's it's somehow yeah doctor
yeah like there was a maybe there this
Bishop on b3 originally and they wanted
this book do you have an idea to work it
as a bishop on b3 Queen g3 for instance
wins immediately just much simpler I
don't know I really don't know
okay so the next one still a very useful
motive of
okay so aha so we have this position
with white to move yeah it's clear that
interesting yeah it's clear that it is
maybe something with the e5 fork that's
one thing that comes to mind and the
second the second feature of this
position is probably the week the week
back rank
I don't really see what the big deal is
to be honest if I take on these six rook
takes e5 I'm just winning this piece
there's really no way around it
rook t6 Queen d6 it's important to play
greentext e6 work 265 first exchange the
Queen then play e5 because route e6
Queen d65
he has Queen c7 or queen b8 and we
cannot take on f6 because of this pin
maybe this is the simple point yeah now
we first need to trade and then play a 5
on e5 he plays Queen c7 and we recognize
that we have a pin we cannot take on f6
so we have to trade first and then win
the piece so not that not that difficult
but sometimes easy to miss those little
things ok the next one
hmm that's a funny position we we are on
a king hunt here black is what are we
done with down one piece right yeah
we are down one piece and we definitely
want to checkmate want to checkmate
why Jim okay so we need to check to
check the checks let's see how do we how
do we win this as quickly as possible
you know we basically I only have Queen
and Bishop to attack maybe sometimes a
pawn move can be a resource as well like
g5 but okay what do we what do we need
to check first
I think the first move to check is Queen
f2 yeah I think we need to check this
first if we take with the Queen you
cannot pay we start with that King g5
the screen f5 checking edge for Queen g4
mate if he goes to let's say yeah if he
also if I just take the rook so there's
king e4 maybe after King eform yeah we
at least have Bishop f5 check king
deform when we don't have Queen d2 okay
so this this is not this is not really
enough so after King e4 what else do we
have we can take C 2 and B 2 but is this
enough not sure Queen f2 key form it
really looks like which we should should
win there with a checkmate or something
Bishop f5 check and King before that
really looks looks very very problematic
but I don't see a win don't see it at
the moment
there's some way to to insert a move
quite often this is the solution like g5
check for example this can also be a
point but I'm not sure if he maybe can
just take with the King yeah
we have to really looks like looks very
simple but what about Queen d5 now we
can also check this move Queen g5 it
threatens Queen f5 mate so it's not like
he has many moves against it hmm
and we're threatening g5 check Bishop g5
Queen f5 check winning a piece that's
that's not bad if we check Queen d5
rookie 5 yeah I think that's right yeah
25 is the right move with Queen f5 check
being the threat and there's also the
threat of like maybe it can the other
threat of Queen de Fora
Queen deform and and Queen Queen B to
this kind of thing
I think Wendy 5 should should win this
maybe I'm wrong but I don't want to sit
there like five minutes to calculate
this stuff I think it should win it's
wrong okay yeah this was a slight gamble
because I didn't want to look look
through it at the end I was thinking
that this should win why is it not
winning interesting the interesting
question if we pull up the Nellis board
let's let's check why is non winning
yeah the solution is the check and yeah
taking on between I solve that but I was
thinking that 25 also wins why isn't
this winning I mean it looks like it
looks like it should win hmm
Queen d5 not quite clear to me what a
lot for the swine's defense maybe hmm
maybe you look III I didn't see that one
that's a problem
did this freeze III yeah see I did a
very sloppy job in calculating this
stuff but still I don't understand
they're not winning it seven okay but
okay if I win you're seven man this is
the this is the deal this is the deal I
give this check King here yeah I might
win you seven but I'm not winning the
game probably something if we just look
at this this is nice but I'm not I'm not
meeting I'm not meeting why anymore
yeah okay this is so sloppy so we have
to is the right solution after King II
for I just think I think of me - yeah
well as sort of some of that but so I
didn't follow up on it i thought 25 mean
I didn't see route III at all okay so
the next one okay so I'd like to move
hmm interesting
yeah the long diagonal quite obviously
Esther it's the important thing here we
have equal material right black is fond
of you okay but we don't have we didn't
sacrifice appease or anything so what we
want to check is the various
various sacrifices or attacks on the
long diagonal something that will work
in many cases here is nighty to check
King edge one Queen takes f3 which is
nice gf Bishop a3 checkmate yeah that's
a direct mate but the problem is 92
checking h1 Queen f3
there's rook d7 check why there's a
counter play and all of a sudden I think
we get check mated with the rook on the
7th combined with the Queen so we have
to watch out for the rook coming to to
d7 so I think the solution should be
Queen takes a three
because gf not f3 check King moves
Knight x h4 check and we have won a
piece so I think this is just a win I
don't really see how wide should defend
him yeah so we have won this piece yeah
it's um we should briefly check I
mentioned it already why the alternative
okay just need to put it once to this
this looks nice and it will very often
winning this mu team I mean yeah mate
but here white has this counter play and
unfortunately this is winning yeah we
have no he also has Queen f6 so we go
here
yeah Queen f6 or Queen age sex it's the
same deal so we we have just just pushed
the suicide button so not a queen takes
a 3 is the real solution ok next one
okay
so black is a piss-up that's nice but
White has four points so it's nothing
that we can simply win in the endgame
um fortunately we have an attack with
all our pieces
I'm just briefly thinking it's this duel
with two solutions okay it's it's really
it does not matter if you see one
solution we you should just do it you
just take him yeah I'm 93 winning the
Queen so that's a little bit more than
just a piece and what I wondered is if
we just briefly it's not really
important because the solution is really
straightforward after age three I was
briefly wondering if this is also
winning it's really Academical because
if you have one solution it's good
enough but probably it does win yeah it
leased it when is ministers rook I think
yeah as we attack driving lots of stuff
so he needs to take a thing and then we
take everyone and then we play with the
rook against four pawns probably winning
but the other thing is just like just
over yeah and we should always do that
so let's do a final one for this session
okay we are playing black and white has
a ton of pawns yeah those kind of
positions are always super tricky let's
see if we take wait is this really a
problem I mean the question is the
knight is hanging and the pawn on is
having a saying we can take the pawn if
we want play Queens we apply King c4
King f4 c6 and
this is dangerous what I'm wondering is
if we just take if we take F for he
plays c6 Kingi 5c 757 is a check and
king e5 is also threatening to go all
the way back there hmm okay I really
wonder and if King f4 King c4 group d7
would be a transposition but I think I
think we the key is that here if we take
on f4 now I think we can save on the
rope t7 move kingi five Kings he form
King if v c6 King d6 king b5 King c7
will win and King F ucking C [ __ ] e5
king b5 King yeah this will also win I
think we the case we need to take first
we take on d7 King c4 you can get to c6
temple so I think we take we need to
take first and now we yeah this is this
is the easier line I think here Keaney
five just Windsor see severalty
semblances check and we are just in time
to to catch the pawns yeah I was
iris really I think the other line was I
think more critical in a way if we put
it is to put it on this analysis just
what when I'm sneaking we take on her
form and here I was thinking that
instead of c6 King c4 is a bit more
critical
yeah then unless the city gives us what
what you said on but if root is 7 then
we can also play this on the person I
really don't see the king is freest
honestly and Wow ok that's a surprising
but I think that this is also swinging
why is this winning I think it swimming
as well
this is this is this is the note C King
if I so see six we can we can really
analyze ourselves see 66 King here we
really should win it with King c7 yeah
we will we will start to pick up once
now I think check check on behaved and
then I take a bit a2 b3 yeah this is a
women so the question is there's
something else
give me five I thought this also should
women with Ruby ancient coming yeah I
think this also witnessed but it it's
probably the case that if we go back
just for a moment I'm sorry
take stakes didn't hear Kings before
probably this also when it's we shake it
and keep screwing this up so
I was thinking that c6 maybe is a bit
more tricky
never my plan expects kids really coming
back in yeah I can I can just look back
with the king that stupid I can go in
the sand really key before I've G if I
King be 16 be six okay this is a pretty
sensible women okay so tell another
couple of nice positions to solve I hope
you enjoyed it I screwed screwed one up
really badly when I miss the swoop these
three resources probably you you found
that okay I hope you enjoyed it
I'm back with another tactics training
session next week thanks for watching